head coach of the ucla bruins chip kelly
on the program
and looking good there hair looks good
coach
it's called the shower oh okay i went
beard
and let it all grow for about four or
five weeks and then
i decided i gotta get back into a
routine get up take a shower every day
don't wear the baseball hat
shave a little bit and hopefully that
will push us to getting back to some
type of normalcy
what do you know now about this upcoming
season
this is what i know i know that the
people who say
don't know and the people who know don't
say
[Laughter]
so i think you know we had a meeting
with our chancellor yesterday and all
the head coaches here and
um he's extremely hopeful um but
his quote not i thought it was a great
thing is the north star that will guide
all of us
is the health and safety of the students
and that has to be first and foremost
and
um it was funny when this first went
down
and we were we had a staff meeting again
at ucla and we were just
in the stages of we're not going to have
any fans at the spring sports
um they had it was the week they were
getting ready they cancelled the ncaa
basketball tournament
but it hadn't happened yet i think it
was that wednesday things hadn't fallen
yet
and our volleyball coach john sporad
brought up a great point he said how
many people here would get on a cruise
ship right now
yeah and no one raised their hand and he
said isn't a dorm just a cruise ship
that doesn't float
and then we all kind of said that was
the reality of what was gonna hit
you know and that was eight weeks ago
and i think we've had eight weeks to
work on testing
we've had eight weeks to kind of go
through this um
all 50 states are in some version of
reopening right now but
what happens over the next eight weeks i
think is really what's critical
um especially to our sport and really we
need to be back
probably eight weeks from now we need to
be back by
july 20th or so if we're going to open
the season on time and so there's still
plenty of time in there
um it's just you got to defer to the
experts in this we we
we're uh we're about first downs and
stopping people and
have nothing to really understand what's
going on in this and
as lee corso told me um i talked to
coach a couple weeks ago with
you know the game of football is not
worth one person's life so we better
make sure we got this right before we
get back
how much of a voice do your players have
in this
i think they have a voice you know we
talk to our guys
um we're in meetings we get eight hours
a week with them
and most of it not all of it's spent on
just texas and o's on i meet with our
squad leaders i was just texting with a
bunch of them
about what our meeting our next meeting
is going to be like and some of the
questions that
um you know we need to discuss and then
we'll present to the team but
um i think they're a big voice because
they're the ones that have to play and
they're the ones that
this environment has to be safe you know
it's the same thing
when you listen to the professional
sports um when you talk to the players
is
they're the ones playing the game and i
think we really need to listen to them
i'm looking at your travel schedule
coach what is your 2020 football
schedule
i've got you traveling a total if this
happens about
almost 10 000 miles round trip
by comparison penn state would travel 4
400
miles that's a big disparity there it is
and
again it's the geographics of the west
coast you know there's not as many
states as there are on the east coast
um there's not that tight core order um
like you guys are in
um but our league goes from washington
to arizona
you know and everything in between and
we also have a game at hawaii
so you got to throw that in there and
that's a huge part of that so um
in normal years and by that i mean any
other year besides this year
you didn't really think about the travel
but now you really have to think about
the travel
and is there effects of that and how
does that work
and what's it like when you're on a
plane and how do you social distance on
a plane and
um there's so many layers to this this
isn't a a black or white an up or down
or a yes or no decision it's kind of
it's like an onion it has to be peeled
and it's layered and i think you have to
really let the the people that know it
the best and that's the scientists
involved kind of make a decision on kind
of where we are with it but there's a
lot of things that go into it
and you know like like you said i want
to talk some football with you
and where do you think offense is in
five years
what does offense look like
uh i i think there's a give and take
between the nfl and the college game
um things go up and things go down um
but i just think there's more passing
that's happening at both levels you know
you look at the success
lsu had with you know with joe burrow
and
in the offense that that brady brought
in from the the saints and
you know people it's a copycat league
and this sport's always been a copycat
league
you know and i've heard this statement
and i really believe it if if you
weren't in the room with amos alonzo
stag and the group that invented this
game then you stole your ideas from
somebody so
there's not an original idea of football
right now um people were running five
wides
shotgun dutch myers did it in 1950 you
know and then the game comes full circle
and the game of tempo
um you know sam weish did it
unbelievable in the nfl the buffalo
bills and the k-gun in the 90s you know
then it took off in college game
um but i think it's it's a little bit
more wide open i think because of the
athletes
in the width and length of the field you
have to use it all and how do you use
that is by spreading people out
and throwing the football um but
something will come cyclical and
there'll be a team that shows up that's
just
pounding the rock and running it down
your throat and everybody will say
that's it but
i think just what lsu did last year will
lead i think a little bit more teams to
kind of open up their passing game
well that's why when i saw the titans
and their philosophy was
that we're going to run and run and then
ryan tannehill will sprinkle in some
passes and we'll play good defense
i don't right i don't know if if we get
it's counter
intuitive to what is being successful
now but i don't know if the running back
comes back in vogue
it's tough because i think a lot of it
is what's available there's a
it's like economy it's supply and demand
and a ton of guys are playing white out
and not a lot of guys want to play
running back anymore
um i don't think you know if you want to
find a unicorn in the world look for a
look for a fullback in this country you
know they don't have
you know no one's playing with them and
where are they so if you want to run
that type of offense
you know what do you do and what are you
looking for um and then i think
uh there's something to be said about
being the contrarian now is
is lining up in a couple tight ends and
pounding the football on people because
people aren't used to that
you know when i left college football in
2012 to go to the nfl
um we were the only team that was spread
out and had shiny helmets and when i
came back
two years ago everybody in college
football does it
and so um but it's an up and down thing
dan i i mean you look
at what stanford does you look at us
we're a multiple tight end team just
because we inherited a bunch when i got
here um and it has been successful for
us
um but you know when i talked to our
tight end was drafted in the third round
this year he's the second tight end off
the board devon asiasi by the patriots
and when coach belichick and bill called
me about him he said there aren't a lot
of tight ends out there
you know when i think a lot of guys that
think they're tight that are tight end
are playing wide receivers so it's it's
it's interesting and i think it's fun to
watch the ebbs and flows of the game
in which where it goes but we still are
just trying to
you know get get a first down and try to
get some points well it's like the big
man in basketball
the big man when we were watching
basketball was a true big man now
he's a seven footer shooting jumpers uh
i went to
when i was in san francisco i watched
one of the warriors um
playoff games and i saw kevin durant in
person for the first time
are you gonna be kidding me and he was
just drilling threes left and right
and when you go back to the days of you
know in the old days
some coach would have told him get your
tail down in the paint you know
but the game has changed you know i
think the cool part with there's not a
lot of television on when you watch the
last dance and see how
where those shots were taken you know
and what a great
elbow jumper jordan had no one takes an
elbow jumper now
because the analytics will tell you to
back up four more feet and that's that's
worth one more
point you know so that that game has
changed and i think because of the rules
um and our game's the same but i think
it will there's there's an ebb and flow
to it
we're talking to chip kelly ucla head
football coach could you see a coach
have the same kind of personality as
michael jordan and that be successful in
today's
game
i think if he wins
[Laughter]
it's funny if if you don't talk a lot
and you lose you're aloof
and if you don't talk a lot you win
you're stoic so it really just depends
um you know he's a he's a hard intense
guy and everybody loves playing for him
why because you're winning you know and
it's
um that that usually cures whatever
personality that the
coaching staff or the the coach himself
has
how badly did johnny manziel break your
heart
um i don't know if it broke our heart
you know we loved him the unique thing
about that recruiting
experience was that we had johnny and
marcus mariota in the same camp
um and we were the first to offer marcus
and we were the first to offer johnny as
a quarterback
um and they were both committed but
he was on i would give him credit he was
always honest he wanted something closer
to home he wanted something
and when he got it and he got the
opportunity from coach sherman at the
time at a
m he took it but um our fallback plan
was pretty good yeah
but how great was man jonathan also so i
i think uh
i thought it was phenomenal i remember
in we were asked a question last year at
pac-12 media day who's the best
high school football player you saw and
that's a loaded question
but the one thing that flashed in my
mind is there was a play when we were
watching
his highlight tape where he took off
and went 90 yards for a touchdown um and
they were called back for an illegal
formation
and the ball backed up five yards they
ran the same exact play and he went 95
for a touchdown
and it was almost like uh oh okay we'll
do this
but he was much what he did at a m if
you ever go
maybe go to youtube and i don't know if
they're there um
you watched some of his high school
highlights and they were phenomenal yeah
but you you know that
improvisational skill doesn't work
in the nfl right
yeah that's what everybody said until
that guy in baltimore showed up
showed up in kansas city um but people
have been doing it
go back to the cyclical part of what we
talked about in the ebb and flow of the
game
and i've always have wondered when you
look at some of the greats that played
in the past is
how good would roger staubach be i bring
it up all the time coach
offenses i do yes i i him and the other
one that i always look at i never saw
him play to see the highlights
would have been sammy baugh who led the
nfl in passing
punting and interceptions in one season
i mean
you get some of those multi
multi-athletic guys that can do a ton of
things and
and they would flourish but roger
strawback's the one that i think
i mean him or fran tarkington back in
the day and what he did
you know that was what his his whole
game was and you're talking about two
hall of famers that that would have been
um
there's certain guys and you know dan
that are generational players that
that could play in any type of system
yeah and most of the time us as coaches
will screw them up
you know well i i just remember seeing
roger staubach at navy
and and then he goes to the cowboys and
keep in mind he had his military
commitment so he comes in and what was
he 29 when he got to the nfl
and and i just found him to be that was
that
dual threat where he was really gonna he
could beat you with his arm and beat you
with his legs and he was just a great
great athlete
he was and i i you know i was growing up
during that era and loved guys like that
there was a guy bobby douglas at the
chicago bears that was that running type
quarterback
you know here when i grew up in new
england you know you had steve grogan
uh i think he's the last quarterback to
ever wear a horse caller
you know i remember those days he had
the big old background at the top
it was interesting it was interesting
but as i said earlier you know i've had
guys tell us when we
invented the spread which we didn't
invent we all learned it from other
people that
people were running shotgun five wides
in the 50s
and winging it all over the places the
bobby lanes and the
dutch meyers of the world so um this
game just keeps evolving
um but it's so fun to watch those guys
play because it's the unscripted plays
um that i think are the ones that we
always go back to when we remember
you know in the back of our minds and
you're friends with bill belichick
uh could you could you teach what brady
does
now well i think you can teach a system
to them but the the most amazing thing
about tom brady to me
is just his discipline as a human being
you know he works out at our place
in in when he's in los angeles um
and our place is open to nfl guys
anytime after 11 i think all the guys
know that so they'll come over and use
our facility
every time tom wants to work out at our
place i'll get a text message from the
night before
chip this is tom brady i'm like i have
your number
in my phone um is it okay if i come over
and work out
and he's there at 7am and he's working
out with tom house's quarterback guy
and it's i remember just looking at him
it was you know last year was the middle
of april
and he's working on his front foot plant
and
there's a guy who's won six super bowl
championships and he's looking at his
foot plant
in his relationship to his elbow and his
hip as it comes through
and getting feedback from tom house and
then
kind of trying to get in his mind what
exactly that felt like and you talk
about someone that's
that much of a stickler and that
discipline as a human being
um to be working on the little things
and i think those are the things that
people don't see
you know on sundays they just the work
ethic and the time that he puts in and
so can you replicate that discipline i
don't know that's there's very few
people in the world that have that type
of discipline
it's great to catch up with you coach
love talking football with you
uh wish you the best here during these
uh trying times and uh thanks for
joining us
all right dan hopefully when we are
talking it's about current football we
don't have to get back to the 50s
we could actually talk about being on
the field but i i appreciate you guys
taking time
and you guys stay safe that's uh chip
kelly head ucla
football coach there